[Music]
first on CBS this morning Wired magazine
is revealing its 25th anniversary issue
with predictions about the future from
top tech leaders wired at 25 highlights
the innovations of the last quarter
century magazine has 25 icons of the
digital revolution from Bill Gates to
Mark Zuckerberg to nominate someone they
think will shape the next next 25 years
wired editor-in-chief Nicholas Thompson
is a CBS News contributor welcome
congratulations in 1993 the magazine
said quote social changes will be
brought that are so profound that their
only parallel is probably the discovery
of fire in the last 25 years has that
held up I think so I mean look at how
our elections work look at how we found
our spouses think about how we're
remembered after we die like pretty
close to fire yeah years old do you and
this was a huge deal a magazine devoted
to this in 1993 some people were
probably 5 6 7 years from getting their
first email address yeah so in 1993 we
were so far beyond so far behind where
we are now and it's been constant churn
and one of the things that's funny
looking back at 25 years at Wired is
there has been a tendency to say things
are gonna get crazy
and then we'll all be great but it turns
out it's just things get crazy and they
continue to get crazier how much crazier
from now to 25 years from now I think
innovation only accelerates I don't
think things ever slow down so I think
the pace of change will just keep going
is it exponential each iteration I think
it is exponential each iteration right
as Moore's law as computers get more
powerful help you invent the next
computers things go faster can we say
kudos to you and your team number one
for this the cover number one it's a
standout but that everybody you asked
just talked to in this magazine did I
know we it's the biggies here we have an
amazing list we have great people they
sat for photographs they're coming to
our conference you know we're gonna have
syndra put giant or conference meeting
session in Delhi we're gonna Johnny I've
they're all in the magazine what did you
want to get from them for this issue we
wanted to get from them one reflections
on what made the last 25 years what they
were and then most importantly who they
think will shape the next 25 years what
do they think the trends of the next
quarter century will be I thought was
interesting that Bill Gates and Google's
CEO talked about healthcare innovation
as the next big thing which is music to
my ears yeah there's been a lot of talk
in the issue about how as we
learn more about our bodies as we get
more data about our bodies as medicine
improves people will be able to live
longer lives and not only that it'll
happen all around the world you know if
you look at some of the nominations or
extended Pichai nominates an eye doctor
in India you know Bill Gates nominates a
bio scientist who's working in order all
around the world all right nuke time so
we're gonna have to end it there we look
forward to talking to your hologram in
25 probably at 5:00 job you think that's
gonna be here in 25 okay maybe next week